and then what point did you try
IndieGoGo what year was it um it was I
think 2010 we tried IndieGoGo because
that kind of fundraising had just become
popular and we tried every other kind so
we thought worldwide I'd IndieGoGo so we
went did an IndieGoGo campaign and we
asked for fifteen thousand dollars and
we got it but I gotta tell you that was
hard money to raise I think everybody
has this notion that you go on IndieGoGo
and there's hundreds of people out there
who want to fund films and no mostly
it's your friends and their friends and
it's it intense work and then you have
to give gifts to everybody you know
everybody does it for perks and so it's
very intensive so did it almost feel
like a full-time job was a full yes yes
the IndieGoGo campaign took us three
months to fulfill everything and to you
know to raise all the money and then
fulfill all the obligations that we had
promised we had promised people t-shirts
and posters and things like that and
then we had to mail all that out it was
it was very intensive so do you remember
what you did on a daily basis during the
actual live campaign was it was it again
more emails to people and sharing the
link emails phone calls I have a lot of
lunches I met with a lot of people who
were interested but wanted to kind of
have a personal contact it's a very
personal business fundraising for
something like this and you never know
who's going to lead you to somebody else
you know you have drinks with somebody
and you think they're going to give you
ten thousand dollars and they never come
through with anything and then three
months later they send a friend your way
who gives you ten thousand dollars so
it's not it's not a direct science
that's for sure what would you recommend
to another filmmaker who is considering
launching a crowd
campaign and has a beautiful project but
maybe they don't have the contacts maybe
they don't know that many people were
some of the people that they know aren't
able to give would you how would you
advise them to gauge what their
audiences you know I that's a question
that I really don't have an answer for
my experience with IndieGoGo was very
personal to me and I know that the
people who gave on IndieGoGo were all
somehow personally linked to me I think
there's a bit of a fantasy out there
right now that you can just go on to
Kickstarter or IndieGoGo and put your
project up there and people will come
seeking you but I don't think that
really happens I think it's really a
dirty down in the dirt hard struggle if
somebody knows different than me I'd
like to hear from them but that's the
way I perceive it would you advise
someone who's maybe failed at how funny
to kind of dust themselves off and
regroup and try again because so many
people i think they become and
understandably you're hurt you're upset
hey my campaign failed and then you shy
away from it would you advise people to
just get back on the horse and try it
again get some time well I think I any
pursuit that you do in life is filled
with failures and successes and you
often learn more from your failures than
your success so you know of course you
have to pick yourself up what else
you're gonna lie in the dirt the rest of
your life it's not an option June your
experience with crowdfunding was back in
2010 was still sort of a novelty
thoughts now it's past you were
successful you raised what 15,000 what
your thoughts on it now that is fast
well the time it took the intensity of
it I had three people working on it for
three months the $15,000 probably just
barely paid our salary during those
were their salaries because I didn't
take a salary it paid their salaries
during those months and left some money
for us to stay operating I think now
looking back on it because it might have
been fairly new at that time and people
weren't familiar with it we were
educating our fan base as to what it was
I think my time might have been better
used just going knocking on doors the
way I had been doing and I probably
could have raised at least that much
maybe today it's different maybe people
know more about what these crowd funding
sources are and are more willing but
then I I felt I could have used my time
better frankly
you